speaking of thermonuclear drops here's a
tweet from Elon Musk this is from over
the weekend and yes it has happened the
Split Second Court opens on Monday
excorp will be filing a thermonuclear
lawsuit against Media Matters and all
those who colluded in this fraudulent
attack on our
company all right pretty good and
obviously you're seeing a whole bunch
there here's a bit of the statement this
week Media Matters for America posted a
story that completely misrepresented the
real user experience on X in another
attempt to undermine freedom of speech
and mislead advertisers above everything
including profit X Works to protect the
Public's right to free speech but for
speech to be truly free we must also
have freedom to see or hear things that
some people may consider objectionable
we believe that everyone has the right
to make up their own minds about what to
read watch or listen to Because that's
the power of freedom of speech despite
our clear and consistent positions X has
seen a number of attacks from activist
groups like Media Matters and Legacy
Media Outlets who seek to undermine
freedom of expression on our platform
because they perceive it as a threat to
their ideological narrative and those of
their financial supporters these groups
try to use their influence to attack our
revenue streams by deceiving advertisers
on X here are the facts on Media Matters
research to manipulate the public and
advertisers Media Matters created an
alternate account and curated the posts
and advertising appearing on the
accounts timeline to misinform
advertisers about the placement of their
posts these contrived experiences could
be applied to any platform once they
cure created their feed they repeatedly
refreshed their timelines to find a rare
instance of ads serving next to the
content they chose to follow our logs
indicate that they forced a scenario
resulting in 13 times the number of ads
served compared to the median ads served
to an xuser of the 5.5 billion ad
Impressions on X that day less than 50
total ad Impressions were served against
all of the organic content featured in
the Media Matters article for one brand
showcased in the article one of its ads
ran adjacent to a post two times times
and that ad was seen in that setting by
only two users one of which was the
author of The Media Matters article for
another brand Showcase of the article
two of its ads served adjacent to two
posts three times and that ad was only
seen in that setting by one user the
author of The Media Matters article
we're almost there guys Media Matters
article also highlights nine posts they
believe should not be allowed on X upon
evaluation only one of the nine organic
posts featured in the article violated
our content policy and we've taken
action under it under our freedom of
speech not reach enforcement approach
here's a summary on all of this x will
protect the Public's right to free
expression we will not allow agenda
agenda driven activists or even our own
profits to deter our vision everyone has
a choice on X users and Brands control
uh users and Brands controls on X are
superior to a year ago data wins over
allegations Media Matters does not
reflect the user experience on X as
we've seen in some parts of the world
when free expression is taken away it is
is very dangerous and hard to get back
that's why the people who came before us
fought so hard to
protect without freedom of speech we
lose the checks and balances critical to
a thriving democracy we defend our
individual rights as if our lives and
our flourishing Society depend on it if
you're really in on protecting Free
Speech then we all need to protect it
completely stand with x in order to
protect Free Speech ladies and gentlemen
um is it obvious to you who the good
guys and bad guys are right now like
it's pretty obvious right like Elon Musk
fought this thing for 44 billion doar it
is purging money he is losing every day
he is losing I don't know what he's
losing every day like it it literally
could be millions of dollars every day
the code was screwed up he had activists
working there they had government agents
working there even right now I'm fairly
certain if you've talked to him if you
talked to him today he would say he's
not exactly sure how many bad s are
still at the company right now but is it
not fairly obvious after covid after
Hunter Biden laptop after election stuff
after January 6 after all of the stuff
isn't it fairly obvious that this guy
bought this thing to just make sure a
few more of us would be able to see what
the truth is and get our ideas out there
even if you were only to look if you
remove all of the the specifics that I
just mentioned all those incidences even
if you were only to look at what has
happened since October 7th or the the
horrific incidences the horrific attacks
of October 7th Twitter was the main
place that they were shared right do you
would you have left it up to Facebook or
YouTube or elsewhere to make sure that
people would have been able to see the
the horrific uh attacks that Hamas
perpetrated no of course Twitter allowed
for that that is what this is all about
right now the fight that is happening
right now
is a fight for us to have any ability to
know what is true it is getting harder
and harder it's getting harder not only
for you guys it's getting harder for me
we are being manipulated in ways we
cannot imagine but we must go on offense
and that's why I dedicated Today's Show
to this it is not to say that I agree
with Elon Musk on any everything or he's
right about everything but he's going on
offense and we have to defend the people
who will Who will put their butts on the
line the guy doesn't have to do this he
could get on a rocket today and go to
Mars that's pretty cool I might join him
on that if possible uh but if they are
going to relentlessly attack us and
relentlessly attack everything that we
that is held dear to us then we must
attack them back uh and actually that is
what's happening uh right now in Texas
another tweet from Colin rug just in
just moments after X launched a
thermonuclear lawsuit against left-wing
Media Matters Texas Attorney General Ken
Paxton announced an investigation into
Media Matters for fraudulent activity
this is what holding the media
accountable looks like the Office of the
Attorney General is opening an
investigation into Media Matters for
potential fraudulent activity the letter
said we are examining the issue closely
to ensure that the public has not been
deceived by the schemes of radical
left-wing organizations who would like
nothing more than to limit Freedom by
reducing participation in the Public
Square attorney general Paxton said
this is
big